I'm going to talk a little bit about the
history and development of web font
technologies
well the web was first invented it
wasn't possible to specify fonts the
idea was that the page language HTML
would specify the the structure of the
content where the headings are where
paragraphs are tables lists and will be
up to the opposite of browsers or up to
the viewer maybe even to take taking
into account personal preferences of the
user to actually choose which fun to
display the text in particular
commercial sites but also also authors
wanted to have some kind of some kind of
influence on how their how their content
was being presented and I guess back in
1995 they started with Netscape
introducing the font tag but even back
then it was only possible to refer to
fonts that were actually installed on
the computer and back then there weren't
really very many standardized fonts
across many across different systems
essentially had Helvetica or an
alternative like such as Arial in
Windows systems and a serif font such as
such as x as well and authors had to
specify numerous fallbacks and generic
families Microsoft introduced and they
started the project in around 96 and
they introduced a dozen or so high
quality fonts for web use really
optimized for web use and these were
published under a freeway license
everyone could download them although
there were restrictions or modifying
them or bundling them in other
commercial products and the result of
this was that within a few years
everyone could expect fonts such as
verdana and georgia to be on installed
on pretty much every system as well as
Arial and Times New Roman we've done one
or two videos on things to do with
typefaces in the past often with
Professor Brailsford why does it matter
what typeface things are it if the
website is from from a commercial
company it communicates a certain brand
and the type typography is part of this
brands image
gotta be honest this sounds a little bit
like selling sales speak mumbo-jumbo
let's go and delve under the hood what's
happening technically though with these
fonts I mean are they now embedded in
the websites or what how does it work
well the fonts nowadays are typically
well they can be stored on a server just
like anything else on the website but
quite often they're being served by
third party companies such as Google or
Adobe Typekit and font the usage of the
fonts is also licensed in such a way
quite often per number of views in the
case of commercial fonts because in the
past font it wasn't really allowed to
put commercial font files on the
Internet at least typical installable
fonts that we have on the system on
computer systems like TrueType and
OpenType and put these files and make
them accessible for the whole whole wild
world to download and that's what was
stalling the take-up of web fonts for so
long so it kind of comes down to
copyright does it very much so and the
way the font industry I think between
like the late 90s and maybe 10 years
later with a decline of print the font
industry started to see web fonts as
less of a threat and more of a business
opportunity I guess the transformation
started when there were numerous
attempts at embedding fonts in ways that
they don't get downloaded using
replacement techniques commercial
websites would use headings or it would
use images for headings and other
largest larger pictures or pieces of
text but now these replacement
techniques were becoming more more
complex using either either flash or
scalable vector graphics which would
enable the text to remain searchable by
search engines but still it wasn't
because of the performance issues and
various other desired disadvantages
these weren't proper proper web fonts
and pressure was growing on the industry
to find a solution for authors wishing
to license fonts for web use and make
them downloadable back in the 90s there
were two attempts at a font format which
could be downloaded
readily be installed and probably the
most well-known one one of the two was
Microsoft's embedded open type IOT but
that only worked in Internet Explorer
and it wasn't open it used some
proprietary encryption algorithms and
that's why there was a pushback from
from browser manufacturers and in in
getting the format adopted as a w3 staff
w3c standard and as an alternative they
came up with wofe the web open font
format is what different from it what I
know of us say maybe at ETF or one of
these fonts that you install how
different yes yes yes it is different
it's I guess Windows or your operating
system doesn't you can't install it you
can essentially convert it into a TTFN
but it's missing many features that are
commercially bought font would have
particularly if the website didn't need
it I guess in the most extreme way it
could be subset in such a way that only
the characters of the website uses
actually appear in the font and it's
possible to have a font served up
server-side in such a way for every
single piece of text that you have in
the font more commonly you'd have a
complete alphabet but for example
Eastern European characters might be
left out some features that aren't being
used such as ligatures small capitals
and obviously if the font also supports
any non-latin characters these would
make the font much larger to download
and one of the main benefits of wofe is
a compact file size from manufacturers
is that the right word for them
typeface house' known as font foundries
once those fonts are out there it's over
for them isn't it
um well fonts do get updated from time
to time a good example good more than a
decade ago was that it was the Euro
symbol which gave it gave them an
opportunity to essentially resell update
and resell their products things like
the newer symbol being added is they the
main reason what these fonts get updated
they're certainly one of the reasons
particularly as foundries look at
supporting and ever increasing
a number of non-latin scripts but also
the outlines get reworked and certainly
with respect to web fonts a number of
fonts have been optimized for on-screen
use generally using techniques that date
back to the print era such as a larger X
height the X height is the height of
lowercase characters in released in
respect to the height of the Capitals so
when you say you increase the X height
that means that the lowercase characters
are proportionately larger so there's
less difference between capital and
lowercase characters slightly wider
characters less contrast contrast is the
difference between the thin strokes and
the thick strokes of a typeface and all
this some helps legibility but another
issue that web fonts have brought about
is that of hinting and particularly on
Windows systems when text is displayed
at very small sizes Windows has a way of
rendering the text which is very sharp
but that's dependent on extensive
hinting information being present in the
outlines what is hinting it is
essentially giving it adding
instructions to a font to how how the
the outlines should fit to the pixel
grid and which compromises should be
made so essentially the shape of the
outlines is modified slightly this was
covered actually in a previous so
compute of our video by Professor
Brailsford
how do you decide which pixels of these
vertical stems to be colored in well one
of the most recent developments is the
release of something called OpenType
variations or variable fonts up to now
when a font has been sold with a variety
of styles you'd have a normal you'd have
a ball we'd have a Nathalia could have a
bold italic for example but what would a
designer do if they were they wanted
something in between a regular and a
bold and with variations as possible to
specify really continuously longer
something called a variation axis I
parameter how much boldness
designer wishes to have and this isn't
only for design of potential use but
also for the use of responsive
responsive web pages would be possible
to for example on a smaller screen or a
mobile device choose a slightly narrower
version of the same typeface what are
you talking about there then is
effectively having the parameter like
the size but for boldness or atella City
is that word a well it elicits II I
don't know what this to telling us it
generally that's something that can't be
very it's not a parameter than it makes
sense at least from a design perspective
to make continuous quite often the
shapes for certain type faces it's more
of a sort of cursive style and the
italics have completely different shapes
it depends on the font other parameters
will be like I mentioned before the
optical scaling to what extent should
the x height and con x height being
increase in the contrast reduced or
relative relative width of characters do
we have as well as a font condensed
extended extra condensed and maybe want
to really be able to verify that
parameter can continuously in order to
get text to fit into a certain certain
predefined width
this isn't even a new technology
multiple master was I guess the most
well known product which was available
back in the back in the 90s and that
didn't catch on back then but now with
web fonts fonts are getting bigger and
bigger again because of increased number
of features alternatives and larger
character sets and if it's possible to
reduce the size of the fonts we have to
download if we can download a whole
family font family in one file which is
marginally larger than the kind of files
we have each individual style then it's
obviously very beneficial also for
simply for the delivery of web fonts
even if we ignore the additional
flexibility that we're getting from them
and that's because at the moment you
would download the bold version or the
italic
and the or and and or the all these
different types will be different types
yeah and particularly few want to have
the flexibility of more than just just
force the basic four styles then you
very much very quickly get to 16 or 32
and and it all grows from there and you
end up in fond status with having fonts
that are several megabytes in size now
think of people in the third world who
maybe need non-latin characters support
anyway and at the same time were very
low bandwidth connections and that whole
disk instead of a holding 50 or 60
different typefaces was devoted to
holding times roman and tuned in about
40 usable point sizes stuff like that
the thing that kept us going though the
room is on the horizon if you like where
that to people working for Xerox PARC